[Musique]
22les créait des paysages sonores plus
grand que nature son inoubliable
mélodies dans le film des chariots de
feu lui a valu en 1981 l'oscar de la
meilleure musique sa musique avivait par
elle-même tu enlèves le film et c'est
encore bon pour moi c'est comme une
grande influence définitivement
[Musique]
avec le film blade runner sorti en 1982
le compositeur grec a encore fait sa
marque dix ans plus tard il signe aussi
la musique du film 1492 christophe
colomb également du réalisateur ridley
scott
de marquer quand même la façon de créer
des musiques de films en utilisant
l'électronique mais bien avec le côté
mélodique était était beau ses couleurs
était l'évadé couleurs vraiment vraiment
intéressant et si certains sont classés
oui c'est vrai la part du temps je joue
seul oui je compense ses vrais pionniers
de la musique électronique
vangelis a amorcé sa carrière au milieu
des années 1960 rapidement il est
remarqué par le groupe progressif yes
avec le chanteur john anderson il
réalisera quatre albums sous le nom john
angels
moi je fais que conduit servir la
musique et rien d'autres
[Musique]
musiciens infatigable 26 à composer
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie ses derniers
disques étaient inspirés par
l'exploration spatiale c'est une grande
perte cc c'est triste à chaque fois
qu'il ya un musicien comme ceux de cette
qualité là nous quitte
26 nous quitte à l'âge de 79 ans selon
des médias grecs et serait décédée en
france de la coved 19 il nous laisse une
oeuvre puissante musicalement il s'est
rendu là où aucun autre métal et
peut-être peut-être le rêve se ruent csn
c'est le reste c'est la vraie réalité
ici oui philippe ouimet radio canada mon
rêve
[Musique]